viii Lee this crowd is on pins and  needles waiting for number four to make  his first appearance not the only one on  pins and needles when you're in this  situation you're on Pizza needle to big  victories tryin to the beat as serene  and calm as possible that's his mother  right there  Joan Oladipo supported him through thick  and thin as he was growing up he says he  had so many conversations with his mom  about playing the game he dearly loved  and we are just moments away from saying  Oladipo Czechia has the commitment  Oladipo tank  for coach Nate McMillan and number four  Victor Oladipo is fashion  but then it's an automatic 50 years old  a Depot taste yes it's gotta feel good  about that to your home took the hit  got it up this on first basket for  Victor Oladipo and his return of over e  right by his Chicago Bull defender the  Pacers have hit number 23 in Chicago and  tarnish important with the 24 in honor  of Kobe Bryant